Avengers age of Ultron is officially out
now and if you haven't seen it yet which
I'm assuming you have this is going to
be a spoiler filled review tons and tons
of details have already done a spoiler
free review that reviews on my channel
right now so if you guys want that
version go check that one out cuz this
one's gonna be filled to the brim with
plot details and all kinds of things
that you don't need to know yet you have
been warned let's continue as you guys
know I really enjoyed this movie I had a
lot of fun with it I honestly had a
blast with this movie I didn't like it
quite as much as the first one but that
didn't stop me from really like in the
movie I'm gonna buy the blu-ray on day
one I had a great time with it despite a
few flaws so there isn't really like an
Iron Man 3 level of spoiler to talk
about with this movie I just want to
talk about some of my favorite scenes
some of my favorite jokes some of the
best action set pieces and a little bit
more about Ultron and vision and of
course the way the film ends all the
action in this movie I thought was
fantastic I love the opening chase
through the wintry woods I love the
scene in which Hulk and Iron Man fight
where he takes Hulk and just plows him
down through a building the character of
vision was one of the things I was most
excited to see because I don't really
know that much about him as a character
one of the things I loved about him was
that his look was almost entirely
practical lots of makeup it was so cool
to actually look and see like that's
that's a person right that is a / yeah
that's person that's not CGI and since
they had that hilarious scene early on
where everyone tries to lift Thor's
hammer and he gets that look of fear
when Captain kind of budges it for just
a second that helps set up the
awesomeness of vision just going here's
your hammer let's go when that happened
I was like holy not one of the
biggest things that some people are up
in arms about and some people are fine
with is the fact that the Hulk and Black
Widow are in the middle of a romance
during this movie like I understand why
people may be upset there isn't much
basis for that in the comics there
hasn't really been any hints at all of
that at the same time I'm fine with it
and I'll tell you why I want banner to
have some happiness in his life
the poor guy turns into a giant green
rage monster whenever he gets a little
upset and I like the way some of it was
handled I like how Captain America came
in there and was like hey man you should
go for that ya don't leave that hanging
just you you definitely go for the
made for a good entertaining scene
because that's what makes the Avengers
movies so cool is you're able to see
these characters just interacting not
necessarily the big action scenes where
they're punching stuff which are a lot
of fun but it's cool to just see these
guys sitting around in a room and
talking because these are the kind of
things that we never thought we get to
see as comic-book fans growing up and
you may be thinking well that's what
made the Hulk interesting he wasn't a
happy character you know he didn't have
these things in life he didn't have
happiness in life well you'd be right
the film still ends with him that way
because he's flying off somewhere poor
little Hulk is in a ship just flying off
abandoning everyone and we don't know
what's going to happen so it's clear
that Whedon understands what makes these
characters work but he's also really
good at turning those things on their
heads now a big surprise to me in this
movie was Hawkeye going home and he has
a family
now obviously Whedon is attempting to
humanize Hawkeye and make him someone
that's just not you know Legolas and he
did a good job with that I like the fact
that they have a safehouse and that it
happens to be Hawkeye's house what's
kind of silly is Nick Fury just
appearing there randomly you know like
the certain things like that was like
whoa Nick Fury you are good it's like
Nick Fury just has like a homing device
for all the Avengers he just knew to be
in that exact barn at that exact moment
it was just so random but again these
little scenes make for great comedic
moments like Thor stepping on the kids
Legos and trying to hide them I mean
just little stuff like that throughout
this movie or Tony Stark hoping that the
wall is a secret door and when it opens
and he's like yeah I mean those little
moments are just priceless let's talk a
little bit about Ultron because he was
one of my biggest issues with the movie
once he's established as a villain I
really liked him I'm not talking about
him just his creation really it's so
quick it's really honestly a montage it
was kind of like how the first Captain
America film montage through some of the
coolest moments of him being a super
hero for the first time in his full
costume they kind of montage through the
creation of Ultron it's so fast and then
all of a sudden he's like this thing
floating and he he attacks Jarvis their
brains their computer things attack and
then all of a sudden he's Ultron and I
was with it throughout that sequence
because his consciousness takes over one
of the suits and starts to talk to all
the Avengers and that was all
really well handled it's almost the very
next scene where Ultron is just sitting
in a room somewhere with Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch he's got a body everything
is all worked out his plan is laid out
it was so rushed that was my biggest
issue with this movie really was how
rushed the creation of Ultron was I like
Ultron once he is Ultron I think it's
funny that he is funny I think he's a
badass villain but there just wasn't
that much of him involved in the final
battle either really he was just kind of
flying around and he fought people a few
times but it just wasn't really that
much going on with him I felt like Loki
was a much better villain and in the end
I mean a lot of people say a movie is
only as good as your villain and if Loki
is a better villain that's just another
reason I enjoyed the first film or I
think they picked the perfect character
to kill off in Quicksilver Fox's
interpretation of Quicksilver in x-men
Days of Future past was perfect this
Quicksilver was not as good of a
character in my opinion he wasn't as
interesting there wasn't that much about
him he really wasn't all that great of a
character plus there's that rights issue
between these two studios which makes
that really strange so I can see how
Whedon would sit down and go you know
what we'll have Quicksilver this one
time but they're not even letting us
call him a mutant he's a miracle or
something so let's just kill him off
let's just get rid of him and I think
that was the wise idea because I didn't
really have that much investment in him
as a character I think his death serving
as something that Spurs Scarlet Witch on
even more after Hawk eyes inspirational
speech to her is the perfect thing that
needed to happen with Quicksilver you
guys already know I had a ton of fun
with this movie I can't wait to see it
again I'm looking forward to seeing it
again those are some of my spoiler if ik
thoughts on Avengers age of Ultron also
this upcoming week I'm going to be in LA
I'm going to be hitting the schmoes note
podcast as well as screen junkies movie
fights I can't wait to go on there to
look forward to that guys and thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mint iced